>> RYAN: Hello, my name is Ray Ryan. And I'll
be talking to you today about how we architect
applications at Google with an eye toward
actually putting them out for production.
So, hello, and I need to remind you as we
all have been doing that there'll be live
notes being taken at the Wave at that Bitly
link there, that you can queue up any questions.
And we'll see if I remember how to run the
moderator application to take those off the
screen as well from the microphone at the
end of the talk. So, we're going to talk about
basically two things today; how does Google
architect its web apps and what is GWT 2.0
and its new friend Roo, what are they going
to do to help you work that way too. This
is going to build on stuff that I talked about
last year at our--at a talked with a very
similar name. It seems like all of our talks
have the word architecture in them this year
and last year. The big takeaways from that
were the MVP pattern that people keep talking
about including Daniel and the excellent testing
talked he just gave here a moment ago, and
to try to keep an app--keep your app in the
decoupled state. So, rather than having bits
of it know about each other directly, try
to do a communication through an event bus--letting
parts of the app post events to each other
without having to know so much about each
other. Wow, this program doesn't work the
way I think it does, so I'm going to work
through the next slide and pretend it wasn't
there. There--we have a bit of miscommunication
and there won't be a demonstration of Roo
right now, but presume. Most of you saw or
at keynote yesterday where we announce the
new relationship with the VMware where their
very cool command line based rapid application
development system called Roo is able to generate
GWT applications for you. Not so much to show
it off right now, but the basic idea is that
one sits down with Spring Roo on types of
few commands dictating the kinds of entities
when one's to work with on a JPA resistance
base system like, say, your employees and
their expense reports and so on, what kind
of fields they have, you press a button and
then, hey, presto, a GWT application pops
out. I think in the course of various demos
today you've all seen the sorts of applications
that pop out, and I've got too much to talk
about, so we're going to jump pass that and
look into how that app is architected, why
is architected the way it is, and how you
can write that way too. So let's talk about
production ready. What does that actually
mean? It means a lot of things here. You need
your app to be well tested, secure. You need
to be paying attention to what's going on
when your users are using the thing. It needs
to be able to scale so that you got lots of
people able to use it, and you got at least
a decent number of developers where lots probably
means more than one; able to work on the thing.
As a web application it needs to be bookmark
friendly, it needs to be crawler friendly,
and it needs to appeal to more than just the
English speaking fraction of the world. I'm
going to talk about the few techniques to
achieve all these goals. The biggest one is
isolation, which knocks out a lot of these
concerns right off the bat. We're going to
talk about instrumentation, which we're going
to actually use to do that monitoring and
let yourself keep in touch with what your
poor users are experiencing. We're going to
talk about trading your users with love suspicion
to protect them from people who are pretending
to be themselves. And we're actually not going
to talk about localization because we talked
about it a bit, actually, this morning not
yesterday during the GWT UI overhaul talk.
So take a look at YouTube for that. All right
so, isolation. This is the bulk of the talk
and the bulk of the time. There's a--I'll
maybe do a bit of a departure from some of
the talks you've been seeing today and the
talk I did last year, there's going to be
not whole lot of code in front of you today
and a whole of boxes in the lines. And that's
the large part because the techniques I describe
or, you know, pretty generally useful, the
code that we're providing to get to going
on this. We're frankly right in the middle
of writing ourselves. We've released today
the 2.1 snapshot of--or the snap shot of the
2.1 release of GWT, that embodies some of
this stuff. A lot of it is going to change
before we actually get to the next snapshot
until they release this. So we're going to
talk a lot more about the concepts that we're
implementing toward and I'll try to be honest
about which one's exist yet and which one
were still very vaporous. So I keep talking
about this Model Presenter View--Model View
Presenter pattern where the idea is to make
sure that the bits that are worth testing
actually stay here in the presenter, in the
middle that is the intermediary between whatever
model objects you're working with and the
slow and cumbersome down based view objects
that actually get them in front of your user.
And as mentioned earlier this gets discussed
in really beautiful detail by Daniel Denalados
at the talk that he just wrapped up here.
I really encourage you to go ahead and watch
that. There will be points over the rest of
my talk where I contradict points that Daniel
just made. I'm wrong, he's right, and I'm
going to go back and change some stuff now.
But there's no time now. So, on we go. So
let's start--let's work our way down from
through this box, talk about the parts of
the triad here and what are new app framework
and the Roo code generation they're going
to do to get you there. When you're in a web
app, we've encouraged you to make your model,
your so-called model a very simple object.
We don't really think that JavaBeans with
property change events and that kind of thing
work terribly well. We encourage you instead
to use more of a DTO for your--for your model
portion. The odds are that the object that
has the--that embodies the things that the
users are thinking about is a dumb little
bag of properties. Hopefully, it's the same
thing that came across the wire when you made
your RPC request. And, in fact, that's how
we've implemented the system that ROO is generating
to. We've got a JavaScript objects that--JSOP
loads that are created on the server request
time that make it across the wire to reevaluate
the instant to reach the browser and they
don't become anything more complicated than
that until as individual properties are asked
for. But when you tell people who are building
an enterprise app and I've got this beautiful
Java model and they're writing into this cool
GWT tool which should be able to do all of
their job and they want to share their code
that they've got to go ahead and write something
that look sort of like their model but really
not quite the same, they get all grumpy. And
they say I don't want have to write the same
thing over again. Everybody tells me not to
repeat myself, why are you guys making me
work so hard. And we're going to hit on the
theme here where possible between Roo and
GWT, we're trying to let the tools do the
repetition for you. So, where you are using
the tool like Roo to actually define your
domain objects the guys who get to persists
on the server-side and you validation logic
in business logic. And that kind of a thing
will run the tool that finds very similar
looking data objects, DTOs extracts them out,
make sure they live in a form that can make
it across the wire for XHR request and lets
you work on from there. So I have a little
gear there to indicate you didn't have to
write that, the tool load it for you, and
the tools are going to do it's best to maintain
it for you as well. This is sort of an idealized
MVP platonic model view of this type of thing.
Let's look at more of what's actually going
on in the code that's getting generated by
Roo right now. And you want to hold on to
these slides because I noticed one of the
questions on the live Wave earlier was words,
the documentation for this alleged application
framework, this is it. So what we're looking
at here is on the right side of the screen,
it's what's going on the servers. So, we've--we're
making a request for--to read for a bunch
of employee objects. Find mail, the employee
objects or find me the employee objects from
10 to 50 because that's what showing in my
exciting new database widget right now. We
provide the stack servlet not GWT RPC but
a new ground-up implementation in part, because
we're probably too prone to reinvent the world
and in part because we want to make sure that
what we're working on here is going to be
mobile friendly, and GWT RPC can lead to heavy
weight code. A brand new reusable servlet
that will take the employee, knows about the
DTO that corresponds of the employee, serializes
the JSON, send that across the response to
coincide request factory object. And when
we generated the DTO that we showed you before,
the employee record that comes out of--that
corresponds to the employee domain object
we also generated a series of request objects
for you. So your client code was able to instantiate
the find me so many employees or find me employees
via this characteristic object which correspond
to static service methods that you define
at Roo time on the server-side. I talk through
this backwards, but I'm just going to keep
on talking. That we built for you as well
as the record that comes back on the other
side. And so the flow on your code is, I know
I need to sense--I know I need to displace
some stuff to my user, click all, instantiate
this request object that somebody else wrote
for me, fired it off, and the DTOs come back
from me and I can concentrate on my presenter
code. So that's the read side of the equation
but I don't just want to read these things,
I also want to mess with them. So besides
the fact that we're providing you a family
of request objects that correspond to the
finders that you declared you wanted, we also
have a general sink request object. What's
going on in the bowels of our friendly request
factory here is that it is keeping what should
eventually be but is not yet in the 2.1 snapshot
a cache of these records, of these value objects.
So when--it's time for me to change one of
these things, we've got convenient methods
for me to say, "I'm the presenter and I'm
working on an employee record." I know an
employee record has a bunch of properties,
like its name, like its boss, like its display
name, I'm going to set those up. And now,
I want you to sink those to the server for
me, the code that you don't have to write
that we provide, looks at the properties that
you've changed. If it sees that--to take just
the difference between those and the properties
that we're actually received on the last request,
sends that delta back down to the request
factory servlet where it's calls the standard
service methods, like a JSR 303 validation
code fire, gathers up any errors that were
reported, sends them back across the wire
for display if they were there, and otherwise
sends back a "everything's okay" type of message.
At this point another per entity class that
we generated for you, a change event is fired
off to the event bus to let in the other parts
of your UI that are interested in employees,
hear about the fact that somebody, they don't
know who, has mess with these things, presuming
that they were no validation errors. If there
were errors, no broadcast, only the person
who fired off the request cheers about it.
They'll display the errors and so fort and
so on. And the sink request can take care
of any creation operation you need to do,
any updates, any deletes. The idea is that
the pattern that we've been telling you to
write your apps toward for the last year,
we tried to implement the bulk of it for you.
But still all we've taken out of the equation
so far are DTOs. You're on your own with the
presenters. You're on your own with the views.
And presenter themselves can be kind of a
repetitious thing at least on the on there
outside. They all kind of need a way to get
their hands on the view they're going to write,
you need to pass state into them, and you're
going to do at least some copy-paste getting
started with those. And for that matter, we're
trying to generate the entire application
for you. So, how are we going to get into
that business? What we've decided to do or
I shouldn't say what we decided to do, it's
more of what we decided to steal from other
people at Google who work harder than we do
an actually build applications, is a pattern
called activities and the activity manager.
I talked last year about a place change concept,
a notion of a system to listen for browser
history events and tell the rest of the app
or the event bus, "Hey, there's been a new
place that's going on." But we didn't talk
a whole lot about how to react well to those
place changes when they happen. Within the
company kind of two semi-frameworks have grown
up, one building very literally the place
change notion that I talked about and that
turn into a framework that nobody else quite
understands and has figured out how to generalize,
and another written by Tim that were big fans
of this new fangled Android thing that was
coming out of the time, and especially it's
notion of activities. And we're leaning towards
stealing that one because more people had
figured how to reuse it. The activity name
is really good, but I don't want to imply
too much here because while we stole that
nice activity name, the life cycle here and
everything doesn't look a whole lot like what
Android does, just more of the concept is
the same. So just like we generated this DTOs
for you to serve as your model objects when
you run your friend Roo and it generate a
nice app for you that your user can navigate
through to edit things and display lists of
things, is generating instances of this activity
interface to actually run the show for you.
What's actually going under the hood looks
something like this, you say that our friend,
the place change event is still actually noted
there and the code that's in the snapshot
right now. We have both place change footing
around this sort of a primitive low-level
the user wants to go somewhere concept without
a whole lot of actual behavior associated
to it, and as primary consumer is a new class
called the activity manager. I just configured
with the map that's responsible for making
decisions like when the users goes to a place
in the app called edit a record of idea or
whatever, we're going to instantiate this
record editor activity presenter type of thing
and started going. So we've got a nice little
life cycle going of the event bus; the event
bus notifies anybody interested in the app,
"Hey, the users had a different place now."
And the activity managers that are listening
first see what activity they're running at
the moment, tell it to stop, go away, you
don't get to play anymore. And they look at
configuration and find the next activity to
instantiate or to reuse, probably instantiate
and tell it to start, and then that's it.
Nothing else goes on at this point until the
activity has had the chance to fire off and
an asynchronous request back to the service
to pick up whatever state that it needs to
render itself, to set up a widget that it
may have handed after this asynchronous strip,
the activity manager gets a call back, "Here's
my widget, I finally have something to show
you, display it to the user now." This is
all a long wended way to say that the activity
is a nice little mini-application within your
application that gets told by somebody, you
go now, makes an asynchronous request to get
it state with any lock that's going to hit
a cache on the way and that actually go over
the wire the second or third time that it's
called and short circuit right away, but maybe
it won't. But asynchronously, it will finally
call back and say, "Here's some UI that is
interesting for me and I'm going to present
it like you'd presented for me now." Because
the activity is isolated like this, all it
knows about is that it's time for you to turn
on, do what it knows how to do and then let
somebody else handle, actually, putting that
state--get some view state in front of the
user, it can run in nice isolation. It's really
easy for me to write a mini-application that
does nothing but test my individual activity.
If I want to really focus on the expense report
editing logic in my app in an interactive
way that I can refresh the browser while rebuilding
my entire app, I've got a way t do that. If
I want to write a nice little isolated JRE
unit test. I've got a nice unit through which
I can do that as well.
That's the basic point of the activity it's
a standard pattern for your presenter code
to actually adhere to so that somebody else
can be in charge of actually firing the things
up and firing them down. As I started to imply
here, because the activity is so self sufficient,
because it's not relying on other parts of
the app to have actually made upstream requests
and so on, is something that can run by itself
and that's makes it a very bookmarkable and
a very crawlable piece of your application.
Each activity is expected to be fired into
existence as a side effect of a browser history
event when the user clicks on the back--on
the fourth button, maybe hits a bookmark and
is really expected to be very self sufficient.
That means that it's very bookmarkable somebody
is going to go to the example.com#report number
1, duh-duh-duh-duh-duh. And the activity should
be able to take care of everything from there.
If you've been paying attention to what's
been announced on various blogs, et cetera
of the past year, you'll know that Google
now supports a convention away for Ajax applications
to declare themselves to be crawlable. So
if you've written your app and is bookmarkable
manner, you introduce a little bang after
the hash sign in your bookmarkable URL, you're
certainly giving a clue to the Googlebot that
you are also a crawlable Ajax app. I'm not
going to go into the full crawlability life
cycle here because that's covered in great
depth at the link that you see down here.
But by building your App in the style, you're
a good portion of the way to making yourself
available to the kind of indexing, getting
more hits and getting more users. Follow the
link for more info, please. So we've got our
DTOs being generated, we've got our activities
being manage force and the initial version
of them having been written for us by a code
generator. We still have this view code to
write. And what you're shooting for with your
view code is something that's too boring to
write and too boring--or too boring to test,
which means it's probably not going to be
a whole lot of fun to write. So we are going
to regenerate those for you as well, and we're
going to use a new GWT code generator to support
you along the way. And new editor support
interface whose job is to do a lot of the
data binding activities for you. And coming
up here we have about the only code slide
that you'll see in the presentation today.
We're shooting for something like this, you
imagine that you're looking at the code behind
a view that's going to take an employee record,
let's go into put that in front of your user
with the name filled and the name text box
and the display name and display text box
and so on. When you're finally writing that
code that comes down to a lot of employee,
get name--or sorry--"employeetextbox.setvalue.employeerecord.getname"
and that kind of stuff over and over again.
When it comes time to pull those--that information
back out of the UI, you'll write a lot of
the same get methods; "textbox.getvalue" and
set that into the record and it's really rather
tedious. It gets even more annoying when you
get to the point of having validation errors
that you need to display to your users. The
odds are that most of them you've tried to
do some the client side and we do intend to
automate a lot of client said revalidation
for you not in a snapshot yet but will get
it there. But most of the interesting validation,
especially, in the business logic validation
is going to happen back in the server, at
which point a request will--been fired, a
response will come back, and you'll have a
mass of errors tied to a particular field
which you then have to route to the show to
the appropriate bid of UI, the same generated
class should be responsible for noticing which
errors respond to which fields getting them
tied to the appropriate bit of the UI and
put the cute little red flag at the right
spot. The support class is also very capable
of letting you know if anything has actually
changed here, so that when you want to write
your logic for, say, your save button. And
whether that should be enabled or disabled,
there's automated way to ask, "Has the user
actually typed any values that don't match
the backing model object that I'm displaying
here right now." You've got an easy way to
know whether you need to warn the user, "Hey,
you're about to leave this part of the app."
And throw up a warning about the changes that
they are about to lose. So, this is a--when
I hinted at the beginning that there are contradictions
between, what our friend, Daniel, said in
his testing talk and I've said right now,
here's a spot where I suspect that we are
aiming at the wrong layer. The way the code
is generating itself right now, what I'm implying
here right now is that you've actually got
a fairly complicated view class that knows
about your value object. You can crumb a value
object into it and you can do all kinds of
display, let the user mess with things and
pull it back out again. The class does wind
up actually being very simple provided you're
actually using the support object here to
do all the fairly complicated but mechanical
marshalling in and marshalling out, maybe
that's the right space, maybe that's the wrong
space. It may turn out that by the time we
shipped this monster in GWT 2.1, our friend,
the data binding classes moved up into the
presenter level maybe, maybe not. But that's
the approach that we're at right now. Okay.
So we've talked about isolation and we've
hit a lot of the points that we said that
isolation would cover for us. We're well tested
now because we can do all kinds of testing
on our nice isolated electivity objects. We've
got a lot of developers going because my activity
doesn't know anything about your activity.
They're not very likely to have side effects
on one another. We're bookmark friendly, we're
crawlable because each of our little activities
can run in isolation from everybody else.
We haven't really gotten to the lots of users
promise and none of this actually feeds into
that, really have sort of--just sort of crammed
that one into the isolation theme because
I like it the way it all shaped up and I wanted
to look it together. The way that we're getting
there in the apps that we're generating with
Roo or that we're deploying on App Engine
is by encouraging you at--to work in against
a subset of the JPA feature set. The app that
you saw generated today or start generated
and demonstrated the keynote yesterday was
a proper JPA app. It can be deployed to any
JPA backend and that includes the App Engine.
And the reason that's able to be deployed
to the App Engine is that it's stayed very
far away from relationship, reference features
of JPA. What happens with providers today,
as your probably familiar with, is Google
specific persistence layer called the Datastore,
and the Datastore can scale up to scary big
numbers of records and maintain all kinds
of speed and responsiveness. But the way that
it can do that is by being very restrictive
about what kinds of relationships you can
have between the records within an application.
If you want to maintain that kind of scale
or the way should put it is when you're riding
one these apps you cannot have a choice. Do
I want something that's going to be super
portable and super scalable to Google levels?
And there's features of JPA that I should
stay away from. And our intention is to have
Roo able to keep you on the guidelines, keep
you within the boundaries for working to that
scale if you want to, or if you decide that
you want to build and deploy anywhere, anywhere
except GAE because you just want things to
be scaleable enough but you're not really
going to be doing millions of users and billions
of records just the usual hundreds or dozens
or thousands for an enterprise app, go ahead
and use the rest of the features. So regardless
of which of those styles that you choose,
persistent side for your entity objects, and
let me say a little bit more about that, when
you're making this choice between using real
references or not server- side, what you're
actually choosing between is, does my employee
record include a boss field that is of type
employee or does my employee record include
a boss field that is type long, the idea of
my--the idea of my other related boss, my
rather related employee. Am I going to manually
maintain the code for navigating from employee
to employee to his expense reports and so
on or Am I going to use the features built
in the JPA to make this kind of thing more
convenient like I'm used to. That's all server-side
decisions, that's all server-side cumbersome
code; someone which we hope to actually automate
for you and there is support. Client side,
it doesn't make a whole lot of a difference.
Client side you pretty much always want to
be working in this--this record doesn't accidentally
pull along that record and accidentally pull
along his related records and their records
and so on, kind of transitive explosion nonsense
in your web browser code. That's why we pushed
the notion of going to DTOs in the first place,
by not trying to bring over your server-side
business objects into your browser mechanically
without thinking about it. You're never going
to be accidentally pulling across the entire
object graph when all you really wanted was
to know somebody's first name. So whether
you server-side code is working with full
references and pointers to pointers to pointers
or not; client-side, your code will already
have been written in style of, "Okay, give
me the employee. Okay, now give me the related
records. Okay, give me this, give me that."
So you've actually a lot of flexibility in
about where you're going to choose to deploy
regardless of which style you choose to write
in. So I think I've exhausted isolation. I've
talked about that as much as I really can,
but we still have other things that we needed
to do to have a production ready app. We need
to instrument it, we need to know what are
users are actually going to be doing, and
there's a sort of three things that we need
to do to get there. We need decent logging
we need stack traces so that when things go
wrong we have hope for figuring out what actually
happened, and we need a pattern that we're
referring to now user actions. Again, something
that's I'm stealing from several very successful
Google teams, and let's go on to more depth
on each of those. So logging first and foremost
is a pretty obvious thing that has been sadly
lacking inside the GWT tool kit proper for
mail ever. There's a very popular package
that's outside of GWT, the GWT log package.
You can find it on code.google.com. It's in
wide use within Google. It's in wide use externally
to Google. A guy named Fred Sauer, we now
have--actually happens to work for us as its
maintainer. As of GWT 2.1, you no longer have
to go outside of GWT in order to get what
should be a fundamental service of your app.
We actually have honest to goodness Java Util
logging emulation in GWT as of this snapshot
and it will be ready for primetime as 2.1
actually ships. And the difference between
the Java Util loggin, let's move into GWT
2.1 in Fred's excellent package is that we
actually were able to provide the standard
Java Util logging API rather than having to
make some compromises. Fred isn't an exact
match and for the very good reason that at
a time that it was written there was no way
you could implement to a standard Java Util
logging API which encourage you to have logger
objects around to talk to you directly rather
calling any aesthetic methods. There was no
way that the GWT compiler of the day could
completely dead strip code written in such
a style. What if you decided you want to turn
on the knob and make sure that what to put
your users actually wasn't going to cause
in many trouble. Somewhere along the way the
GWT compiler got a lot smarter, I'm not sure
exactly when or what happened, but when we
sat down to--we just--we revisit this problem
and see if it's still the case that we have
been convincing ourselves and telling--preaching
the people for years that you can't do that
anymore, it just wasn't true. My officemate,
Una, did some tests and very empirically showed
that no matter what kind of stuff you throw
at a logging object these days, if that logging
object is instantiated through a code path,
it could never have returned anything but
null. It will simply evaporate. I'm hand waving
a bit here about what the actual coding patterns
are that you need to follow in order to make
sure that kind of thing a happens. But it's
fairly straightforward. If you want to play
with this today, it's in the snapshot. Documentation
will follow showing kind of dos and don'ts
about how to work with these things to keep
the safe. But it'll all be there. So, anyway,
a long-winded digression; what you actually
want to do with this client side logging to
keep an eye on what your users are up to is
keep a buffer of the logs accumulating on
the client side. It's up to you to decide
how much you actually you want to hold on
to, how much you want to send down right away.
But there's no reason to be sending an RPC
request every time any kind of a logline happens.
Kind of the meta-point here is just because
you can set a knob and dead strip all of your
logging code if you want to, there's no particular
reason that you need to dead strip everything,
if it's going to be useful to keep an eye
on the health of your app. Maybe you're just
going to turn the trace level of knob up to
the info level knob or the super info level
knob or something like that. But with each
logline that you leave in there, you accumulate
them all, server side; and you listen to our
friendly event bus for announcements that
there's a request that's about to hit the
user. Something I meant to go into in the
request factory section of this. What I forgot
about is that it is our intention to have
the request factory, provide both batching
and caching services for you. So that while
you're a nice little isolated activity objects
are firing off the request for this and the
request for that and so on, they're all going
through a nice centralized point in that service
object, the request factory service object,
so that with each tick of the event loop,
we can send an entire batch down for you.
And that gives us a nice train that are accumulated
logging statements over the last event loop
tick or longer if that's appropriate to us,
can go down into a single--to hitch a ride
along that same ride. Oops. Yes, there's more
I want to say on this, but we'll come back
to it later, so I won't confuse myself now.
So logging coming now but you can use it today
in the gwt-log package, and you probably already
are. Stack traces. You've probably know that
you do get some kind of a Stack Trace on most
modern browsers with one glaring exception.
But the interesting thing is that you actually
want to get this information to the server.
You've actually had support for doing that
kind of thing in GWT for a little while now.
I believe with GWT 2.0, if you rummage around,
you'll find a convenient object called the
HttpThrowableReporter. And his job in life
is to take a throwable and get it to the URL
of your choice in a simple little JSON format
that you can then start logging server side
and keeping track of yourself. gwt-log, the
package that we were just talking about comes
standard with the remote logging service,
which is also capable of doing this kind of
thing. Grab a throwable, stick it in to a
logging statement and it'll reach the server
at some convenient point. What people might
be less familiar with is that it's possible
to make these exemptions actually useful.
What happens normally with GWT compiled code
is lots of good obfuscation happens, we're
squeezing all of the juice out, so that your
users don't have something bloated. But as
a result of that if you're using gwt-log,
if you use the ThrowableReporter to capture
these exemptions that happen in production
time, and send them down to your server, you
get thingy little gibberishy sort of symbols
that its kind of hard to take--make--get any
information out of. With GWT 2.0, it is possible
to re-symbolize these obfuscated stack traces.
We've actually even documented that fact,
if you follow the URL that's on the screen
there. And my apologies if it's too small
to read, but it is what it is. I'm sure that
when you scribe back over to YouTube video
with a magnifying glass, it'll be no problem.
If you follow that page, you'll see a recipe
of how to get these all done, but it is rather
minimal documentation. We'll try to follow
up on this and get you a little more repeatable
recipe. And it is also, of course, our intention
that the apps, like it generated by the Roo
tools will have those kind of stuff configured
for you already. It's not there yet but it
is on the roadmap and it should be part of
the 2.1 release. But these stack traces besides
being obfuscated, although, now you know how
to solve that problem, are also kind of granular.
If you even have the things, and the sizeable
portion of your users will be using browsers
that don't provide them, the best they're
going to get you is function level--method
level information. If you got a Stack Trace--an
exception that is thrown inside of a method
that's 100 lines long, you're going to be
told--it was that method. That was the one
where the problem was. But you've got no line
number information. There's not a lot you
can do with that point. That problem also
has been as solved as it can be in GWT 2.0.
There's a new knob that you can turn on called
Stack Trace Simulation. This gets you any
kinds of exceptions at all on browsers that
don't actually provide stack traces, and it
can be set--I've lost track of how configurable
it is. At one point the plan was to let you
decide how much emulation it does. I know
that if you just turn the thing on by setting
this property in a "gwt.xml" file. We actually
will keep track of line number information.
Do all kinds of crazy stuff behind the scenes
to give you a full useful stack traces when
they're thrown. The down side of doing all
of this is that does make your apps slower
and makes your app fatter. Not as much slower
and fatter as you might fear, I think, the
speed numbers that I recall on the order of
a factor of two or so. The code bloat was
10s or 20% something like that. Don't quote
me on that, I'm making it up. It's enough
of a difference that you don't really want
most of your users working like this, but
it's small enough that you might be tempted
to actually sneak a few of them out there
and make it available to people. One technique
that you might do is compile a version of
your app that you can point your users at,
that has the emulation put in. So you get
a report of, "This terrible thing is happening
when I ran my app." You can shoot a response
back saying, "Well, could you ran the app
and add to it this nice little debug flag
for me? And we'll see what you get, or I'll
watch my logs as it goes on." And you can
use this configuration set-up in your "gwt.xml"
to make that possible for your users. You
could use more complicated approaches to actually
define percentage experiments. One team does
inside of Google. I believe, they said they
were going to, is for their Internet Explorer
users who might need certain other profile--certain
other characteristics. I don't remember exactly.
You know, a percentage of interesting users
to a version of the app that actually has
the full instrumentation compiled in like
that and collect the exception reports that
appear there, and so they actually have some
picture of what's been going on without slowing
down everybody in the world as they do it.
And, again, once you have your hands on these
exceptions client side, it's really not all
hard to let them trickle back to the server,
log them, start running your apps on them,
that kind of a thing. So, instrumentation
the final piece of the puzzle there are user
actions. Here, at my most hand-wavy. It's
this code that has basically been designed
and been discussed among teams that use this
technique inside the company. There's nothing
implemented yet in the snapshot. Monday morning,
the ground breaking begins. But the simple
but tremendously powerful idea here is that
you associate portions of your app, piece
of your app that the user can touch with unique
strings, just something to identify them.
Link elements, buttons, tab items, that kind
of a thing. It's really quite simple, in fact,
to set up your system in such a way that you
can have these strings embedded in the "ui.xml"
files that actually define your user interface.
So that when I use my magical user action
link widget, instead of the normal stock link
widget. I can add an attribute that says,
"This is user action. The user has asked to
edit something," that sort of a deal. Such
instrument in widgets when the user actually
clicks them or whatever, make an announcement
to the event bus, because we like event buses.
Somebody else is listening on the event bus
to hear whenever an UI element declares the
user has started action X and they start the
timer. He's also listening to the event bus
for RPC events that might happen as a side
effect of this user action having been started.
So employees are requested, syncs operations
are made, that kind of a thing and keeps the
timer going. As responses are received over
the next few--microseconds or hopefully microseconds,
the activity manager is listening for a paired
event from the request factor announcing,
"Okay, I've gotten the responses for this."
When it sees all the responses, matching all
the requests that happened after that the
user did something, event was fired. The timer
shuts down and we log something. And we're
back to taking advantage of our friend, the
logging the system, to accumulate our user
action logs, client side and trickle them
down to the server as they're actually needed.
With all of this stuff, we keep talking about
accumulating things client side, letting them
ride the batch back down, it's up to you where
you want to make the tradeoff of talking to
the server too much and bothering your users
and talking to the server too little and losing
information. The team that's been particularly
pioneering with the user action pattern started
off keeping, I think, their basic aoristic
was whenever we see a request going down,
we'll flush our accumulation--our accumulated
logs of user actions and whatever else. And
of nobody is asked the server for anything
in 30 seconds, we'll fire off a request of
our own. That proved to be too long. A lot
of information was being lost. It was still
hard to debug things. They're now at the point
where I think that if no user action happens
for three seconds, they'll actually go ahead
and force a request to go back to the server.
No users have noticed. It doesn't seem to
impede performance at all. And they wind up
with a very sophisticated description of what
users are up to, and in particular what chain
of events led to, perhaps, the exemption that
got logged on the next after the user action
log was happening or it got intermingled in
with the user action log. One other interesting
thing I'd want to point out here is this team
made the conscious choice, rather than tying
these user action descriptions to activities--remember
activities? We talked about those at the beginning.
Rather than deciding that our nice little
isolated activities would be the unit of,
"Hey, the user's doing something. Let's make
note of that and than start logging requests."
They wanted something a lot finer grained.
Once I'm within an activity, I could be exposing
menus, hiding menus. I could be moving focus
between things; a lot of stuff that doesn't
have anything to do with browser history or
states within the application. And so, they
chose to actually make this a very micro instrumentation
sort of feature. It's worked out nicely with
them and they've got one of the most beautifully
designed apps in the company as a result.
I mean, not only can they keep an eye on the
quality, the exception reports and bugs that
are happening. They also have a good notion
of what features get used, what features don't
get used. They're able to keep--they're able
to discover that--this really cool and important
feature that we just implemented and spent
a month of engineering time on, nobody can
find it and nobody clicks it, maybe its time
to move that around. The more information
you have, the more information you can react
to. So that's monitoring. Now, let's talk
about suspicion. I don't have a huge amount
to say here. I just want to point out a couple
of features that have found their way out
from behind the curtain recently. What this
is all about is guarding against cross-site
attacks. And there's a kind of a cute little
thing that's sort of snuck into--let me see.
What did I say? I wrote it down there. I don't
have to remember. Its making its debut in
GWT 2.1 and that is our habit of sending down
on every request in GWT RPC. A header that
tells you the strong name of the particular
GWT-Permutation, your client code--excuse
me. We set a header on every request with
this magic name X-GWT-Permutation. The header
is actually there to help in stack trace the
obfuscation in order to know what symbols
are actually there in the stack trace. You
have to know what flavor of your app was compiled,
but a clever person noticed, "Hey, this header
is going down." Only XHR requests are allowed
to set custom headers like this. XHR requests
are only allowed to return to the domain from
which the code originated. So, it's difficult,
not quite impossible. I think versions of
Flash will let you get around this. But they
aren't difficult from malicious code loaded
through a script tag or by accidentally rendering
some user generated HTML to actually set such
a header. And so, the GWT servlet that actually
fields good RPC request by default now will
refuse a request that doesn't have this header
set. If that's causing you trouble for any
reason, it's very easy to turn their protection
off. Its also nice point which you try to
get a little bit more clever about what kind
of headers you're looking for. It's a nice
override point in the app, but it's there
now. You're one step closer to save. Something
else that has also appeared in the last 24
hours with very little fanfare is a--I guess
it could call it a framework. A new framework
called SafeHTML. This is something that we've
been using internally for quite a while now.
And it's a system for--I'll talk about what
kind of a system it is, but let's talk a little
bit it first about where you can find it.
The Wave team, among many other things, yesterday,
while announcing that they have opened themselves
to all comers, also open source a whole lot
more stuff, including a full Wave web-based
client that took their FedOne client. They've
made a web version of it. The code is totally
open for you to mess with, including a lot
of the interesting display code that Daniel
wrote. And in order for them to open source
that, they had to open source our nice little
HTML scrubbing system SafeHTML. It's something
that we've been hoping to kind of get in to
GWT at some point 2.2, 2.3, it's out their
now because another team got impatient. It's
there for you to find rummaging around the
Wave open source code site and we'll incorporate
into GWT a little bit more robustly at two-point
sometime, someday. So, what's SafeHTML basically
does for you is it tries really hard to discourage
you from ever using the setinnerHtml call,
the problem or the setHtml ware on widgets
setinnerHtml on done elements. The problem
with that call is you--if it they got it builds
DOM. And it can build script blocks and it
can do all kinds of things. And there's a
really good chance that when you're recalling
it, you forgot to make sure that what you're
rendering there didn't come from your user
who intentionally or accidentally wrote/script
rummage from my data and send it off to somebody
else and dot, dot, dot, dot, dot, dot. What
SafeHTML framework does is it introduces interface
called SafeHTML which promises that, "I am
some HTML that somebody very clever carefully
assembled for you in a way that didn't come
from user sources that doesn't accidentally
include extra angle braces to break things
and so on. And you can just go ahead and plug
me in some place." It's--it doesn't get but
by the time it's incorporated into GWT proper
it will come along with the revamping of our
widgets to deprecate setHtml methods and replace
them with setsafeHtml methods to encourage
you when you do actually need to build bits
of HTML. Use a convenient builder object that
knows how to stop these things together where
they're accidentally having--rendering side
effects on you. It also includes a runtime
such--that our friend, SafeHTML builder meant
to be more of a semi-compiled time type of
thing. We have the SimpleHtmlSanitizer that
comes along with it for when you actually
do need to take some information from the
user client side and run it through some--sanitizing
before you put it in front of them. That's
the basic idea of it, but it's like I said,
it's not in GWT yet but it's hugely useful,
it's hugely proven and I think it would be
wise to go ahead and start grabbing it and
using it yourself. So that's about what I
had prepared for you. Just to recap, this
is what we think production ready means and
I think the main way that you get there is
a large part by keeping your bits of the app
isolated from one another. You achieve the
scalability across lots of users if you want
to do monstrously big things on App Engine
by similarly isolating your entities from
one another. The data storage side; this gets
you crawlability, this gets you being bookmarked
friendly, it might get you hits from--with
a search engine of your choice. Your app needs
to be monitored and needs to be instrumented
so that you can take care of your users and
see what they're actually up to, get some
eyeballs in their. And finally, your app needs
to be a little bit wary of just what your
users are getting up to. And, of course, with
our new relationship with VMware and Roo which
I am tremendously excited about, you shouldn't
have to be working so hard to do all of this
stuff. We think that we can let you get a
good part of the way their by generating an
app that sets you off in good habits and good
style. An app that we can maintain at least
a good portion of the plumbing for you as
your app grows and like that, a third point
that I forgot that I wanted to make. So that's
it. Thank you. So I'm going to try to figure
out how to do the moderator thing, but I screwed
it up last time and that was with the program
that I understood. Give me one second to try
to get this going and then we'll take questions
from the microphones. That doesn't work. Does
that work? Copy hyperlink URL. Well, that's
the addressor. Cool--I'm still--I'm not miring,
am I? Okay. And, well, that comes up. Hi.
>> Quick question about safeHtml, do you guys
have any support for a kind of like allowing
basic HTML?
>> RYAN: Say that again, please.
>> Do you know if SafeHTML has any support
for allowing basic HTML, you know, like image
tags or the, you know, bolds and [INDISTINCT]
from the user?
>> RYAN: It's more the idea that you will
use SafeHTML builder to put together stuff
like that rather than--I'm pretty sure that
the sanitizer is not so ambitious to try to
distinguish safe from unsafe tags that user
may provide.
>> Got you.
>> RYAN: I think it's more about making easy
for you to assemble that kind of stuff as
you need to.
>> Got you.
>> RYAN: It also has a many temp--compile
templating system built in to it that I...
>> So the assumption is you've already sanitized
on the way in? The users input...
>> RYAN: Right. I'm trying to think of the
correct answer to that. It's more the assumption,
you know, I can't remember the exact answer
there, but it's pretty well documented unlike
a lot of the stuff that I've discussed today.
>> Cool. I'm sorry with that. Thanks.
>> OK. Hi.
>> Hello. So, if you generate that much, do
you actually need to generate it so you can
use it at runtime like maybe basic HTML and
then use that HTML at runtime, it don't generate
code at all?
>> RYAN: We tend to find that the more--we
try very hard to do as much as compile time
as we can. It's sort of one of the central
[INDISTINCT] behind, how we approach this
stuff. The more we do stuff at runtime, the
more we find the app gets bigger and the app
slows down. That's why there's no reflection
in GWT, that's why there's no introspection.
And what we're generating a lot of code here,
this is--every line of code that we generate
is something that the compiler can consider
whether you've actually executing it, how
your actually executing it, can in-line things
can throw away unused portions and so on.
The more flexible we live things at runtime,
the more we have to leave there just in case
you call it in a way that we won't be able
to tell if you do or you don't. In fact, the
code does shifts in the snapshot right now.
Probably, errors are a bit too far onto the
runtime side. Something that I didn't go into
here is the request factory code is set up
right now so that you can--when you ask for
a particular record, you can actually indicate.
And here's a set of properties that I want
you to include with this record as you bring
it back over. We--that right now, that information
will happens at runtime and we're thinking
that was perhaps the wrong move and that we
should turn it to more something that gets
declared more statically, more declaratively
so that we're not being forced to keep so
much information around free at runtime. Did
that answer your question?
>> Yeah, almost, yeah, but there's some that--called
bloat [INDISTINCT] you have a lot of codes
that's almost the same. So, if you don't generate
it, there is a chance the application will
be smaller, maybe faster?
>> RYAN: You'd think that, and we shouldn't
be completely cavalier in what we generate,
but, typically, when--sorry, I'm trying to
understand the--I hereby promised to answer
the online questions offline after this but
I can't figure this thing out. Typically,
the code that you generate, the compiler will
get rid of it if you don't actually use it,
and the odds are that what your generating
is something that you intended to present
there in the first place. For example, right
now, the stuff that we've shown off here is
not very configurable. It does, in fact, look
at every entity of define server side and
improve generate UI for you for that and RPC
for that. I hope that we can make that a little
bit more selective. So while it's easy to
generate something that will export everything,
you can get--you can take a little bit more
control of if and say, "Well, here's the 20%
of my entity set that I actually want to make
visible to the client." Go ahead and do that.
So we will not be quite so stupid, but I still
think compile time rather than runtime is
the time to be doing that. Hi.
>> Hi. So if you think of a big GWT app like
AdWords or Wave, it seems like a Roo generated
interfaces can obviously hold up very far
into the development of app like that, right?
Because it looks like it's really for CRUD
style interface.
>> RYAN: Absolutely.
>> So in that case, can Roo just maintain
like those DTOs and those event objects for
us and let us do the UI or as it basically
all Roo or no Roo?
>> RYAN: No. It is very much the intent that
Roo--and how Roo is working right now is kind
of generating two layers of stuff for you.
It's got a set of classes that it treats as
very much mirrors, reflections of what's going
on into the side that will keep updating and
keep updating. But on the first run, it also
generates a bunch of UIs scaffold that it--puts
there for you for the first time and that's
not going to touch it again. And one of the
most interesting challenges with this, and
something that we've had been to learn from
then on the guys at VMware is just how to
architect these things, so not only is it
something that you can reuse, but architected
so that something that the different bits
are isolated from each other. So that, for
example, the entry point that is configuring
all of this stuff to put in front of yours,
in the first place, is isolated from, say,
the list of all possible entity editing places
that Roo is going to update and extend and
extend and extend so that I can mess with
the overall application structure while Roo
can keep maintaining the plumbing for me.
>> So if we're going to build something like
AdWords, you could use completely custom UIs,
not even use any Roo's generated UIs at all
but still get the automatic generation for
the DTOs...
>> RYAN: That is very much the intention.
The place where it's weakest in the snapshot
implementation right now is Roo is generating
for you the list of possible locations within
the app to place objects, and we've screwed
up making that something that you can extend
without actually having Roo collaborate everything
you do or taking Roo totally out of the picture
there. So, we're still kind of working on
that, and I think it will all settle in as
we get to real history implementation.
>> So, you would intended...
>> RYAN: That's the goal.
>> So, you'd intend that if someone's that
not using Roo, they would still use the activity
paradigm that you shared with us...
>> RYAN: Oh, absolutely, absolutely there's
nothing at all Roo specific about the activity
manager...
>> Or request factory in that...
>> RYAN: Request factory, all of this should
be usable without Roo. It's a bit laborious
to configure as things are at the moment.
I think we can make it more concise, so that
while it's convenient to get it generated
with Roo you should still be able to work
with it by hand, but we're getting there.
Once you get above that level of the request
factory into the editor support and all this
kind of the thing, we want very much for this
all to be usable whether or not you're working
with Roo. Just like the new data widgets that
we've been discussing, some widgets that we've
been discussing in other forms can work very
nicely with this role but don't require it.
We want the other layers to work nicely together
but not require. We don't want to dictate
to you absolutely every layer of how you work
with your app.
>> Thanks.
>> RYAN: Uh-hmm. Hi.
>> I can't wait for 2.1, since 2.0, we've
been--we started using code splitting and
an application has grown pretty big. Another
thing, you know, if we can actually hosting
our application like at least the static part
on CDN type system where the static files
can be loaded from a different server.
>> RYAN: I'm having trouble understanding
you. You've been using code splitting since
2.0?
>> Since 2.0 and our application has grown
pretty large and we're hoping to actually
host the static files on a CDN, something
like static.domain.com, and do you have any
thoughts or best practices around...?
>> Rick Cromwell would like to take the microphone
and answer that for you, which is good because
he's better than me.
>> CROMWELL: We kind of had run into this
problem at Google. I think AdWords was doing
the same thing. They wanted to host the static--resources
along different server. So Lex Spoon who is
the architect of code splitting, just recently
came up with the thing called the cross-sight
fragment loader--linker or something like
that. I can't remember the actual name. But
it's specifically designed for this used case
so that you can put your static resources
on a CDN, but keep the code split compiled
our facts on a different server. So, that
definitely will be supported, I don't know
if it's in 2.1 or if it's in Trunk or...
>> RYAN: I think, don't quote me on this,
but I believe that everything that's in Trunk
right now is destined for 2.1. It's not all
in the snapshot, but I don't believe that
we've yet set the boundary for what's going
in and what's going out. There's also been
talk--this is not something that's being under
active development right now, but Bob Votaw
keeps looking for an excuse to implement it.
We have our client bundle now. We're just
able to compile in all of your resources and
so on. And what he'd like us to get to is
something that--just take that to--a step
further and build what he calls the server
bundle, where you're able to indicate a bunch
of resources that still are strongly typed
and your code has API access to but which
we don't actually fetch until you want to
use them. It's a little orthogonal to what
you're asking but the same kind of idea.
>> All right, thank you.
>> Yup. I think this is the last question.
>> All right. So activity managers; I'd looked
at some Roo generated code yesterday, that
wasn't cleared to me whether an activity manager
lives at a global level where one listens
for all activities or they're kind of localized?
>> RYAN: Typically, one has a global activity
manager, but it's not a requirement. And then
the scaffolding app that we're actually generating
right now, we actually have two of them. So
all of activity manager is somebody who's
able to listen for place change events, history
events, figure out what's the appropriate
presenter and view to put in front of the
user and put them there. And there's no reason
that you can't have several of those working
at once. What we actually still need to do
is figure out how to actually tile all of
this into the history mechanism and let them
persist there, their state that way without
snapping on each other, without requiring
each other. Stay tuned. And my clock is up,
so I think I have to get off of stage now.
Thank you all.